you've done a lot of voiceover where
I've done I've done a few films and like
aloha shirts do you do your voice cuz
that one thing I love about voiceovers I
don't have to do all this you can go and
look in crazy-bad and I have yeah I have
that's the beauty of doing a voiceover
you walk in there it's it's night and
day from doing a regular film and you
know that already it's like you go in
there and you don't have to memorize
anything if you show up in your pajamas
they judge you but they don't care you
know the checks still clear so you know
it's a lot of fun but I heard you do oh
oh yeah I know I'm not wearing on Aloha
shirt right now I have people now that
that if it was up to me man I'd be
wearing one of these pillows I survived
and jeans and t-shirts so yeah I miss I
don't like dress up but this is all
Candice I have a person but I love your
Aloha shirt I love them I'm not that I
was really cool everyone calls you
fluffy though why I know right I got the
nickname forever it was something that
my mom gave me it's one of those things
work she didn't like Miko you're not fat
you're fluffy I got I got you're just
big-boned that's what I got which sounds
just as gross is bad I will not stop
talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this